Dogs my whole life.
And one of the things that you do kind of notice,
I right now have a golden retriever.
We have,
uh,
we,
yeah,
we have a white lab.
Yeah.
Yellow lab.
And uh,
I've had a bunch of different dogs mastiffs and pit bulls and German shepherds.
No small.
We have a docs in,
you don't have small Dah.
My oldest daughter has a tiny Chihuahua.
It's the [inaudible].
No,
he's the best bark all the time.
Now.
He doesn't bark that much.
He bought us a little bit,
but he's,
he's really smart.
He's actually a Mutt.
He's Chihuahua and Australian shepherd,
but he's like that big tiny,
tiny little thing.
He's the best.
But,
um,
my point being is that you can see if you get a dog from a breeder,
you really can see how they can cultivate certain types of behavior.
Like a good example of my mass diff who passed away this year.
He came from this guy who bred dogs for films and for police training.
And uh,
he was the most calm,
most chilled out dog I've ever had in my life.
He was just a giant dog is 140 pounds,
but he,
you could have them taken anywhere and trust him with a baby and he was like,
hello?
Like everything was totally,
but this guy purposely,
anytime a dog showed any aggression towards people or any aggression towards
dogs,
he wouldn't let them.
So how can anyone not hear the stories like that or no stories like that and not
then also think that genes play a role in human behavior.
Oh,
they,
you have children.
Yes.
You realize it when you have children,
you see it like,
okay,
this is not,
I didn't do this.
This is,
this comes from me.
Yes.
There's certain traits that my children have that I watch and I go,
okay,
this is not this.
I didn't teach them.
They just started.
They were born this way.
I've got my fucked up brain.
You know,
there's something in there like they're not seeing the light.
They don't see how crazy I am.
It turns by her whole heart.
I work working things,
how obsessive I get with things they're just doing.
And it's very weird.
It's very weird because you see it,
you're like,
oh well,
okay,
well how much of this shit that's in me is,
well,
how much of me is me deciding to be this person and how much of me has no
choice?
About half and half.
I would say overall on average across traits,
how much do you think gets passed down through genetics?
In terms of inclinations?
Like like the niche positions?
Yeah,
half on average.
So for example,
about half the Wii,
you know how religious you are or how risk averse you are.
Like I can,
I can about half the variation and how if you look at a group of people and some
are more risk averse than others,
about about half of that has to do with their genes and half has to do with how
they were raised or what environments they grew up in.
So you know,
there's a kind of innateness to many of our qualities and you can shape them.
You know,
for example,
you can't,
you couldn't make me a musician.
Unfortunately I have almost no musical talent.
I can dance,
I think.
I mean,
I think others would even say that I can do that.
Uh,
but,
um,
so it's not just like I think I can dance,
but I can't.
Uh,
but I,
I have no musical ability whatsoever.
I would say I'm tone deaf and,
and you know,
I can appreciate,
I like I,
but I can't produce it.
There's no way you could train me,
I don't think to be a musician.
Um,
but,
um,
so some of it is inborn and some of it is,
is a,
is taught for all of these qualities.
Yes.
It's a fascinating thing to watch.
It emerge from a child,
isn't it?
Yes.
As a parent,
you see where it comes from.
Although we have adopted,
like,
I,
um,
my mother had three biological children and I have two adopted siblings that
come from actually a multiracial family.
I have a black sister and a Chinese brother.
And My mother was an incredible human being.
She died when I was a 25.
She was 47.
Uh,
and,
uh,
we have been foster parents,
my wife and I.
And so,
and we have lots of adopted kids in the extended family in addition to
biological kids.
And so you can see,
you can see the play of genes.
You can see the extent to which the kind of the inherited traits that these
people we all have.
And you see the shaping by how you're raised and you know,
so both are important.
And this is incidentally why if you ever have anyone,
it's not,
it's not nature or nurture.
It's both always almost in every single trait actually.
Well,
that's the case of so many things in this life.
We want everything to be binary.
Yes,
it's,
it's nuts.
It's a total,
we were talking earlier,
it's a total loss of nuance and an inability to see any gray and,
and,
and some people think,
and I think that's what you were talking about,
some people think that we are hardwired to like dichotomies to see,
you know,
male and female and an up and down and good and evil and left and right.
And to simplify the world by finding out.
And that we like it,
that it soothing to us to think that the world can be divided into two
categories.
Yes.
But in fact,
many times not always like up and down is sort of clear,
but many times it can't.
They're shades of gray and it's harder.
That's harder to live in the gray.
Yes.
I completely agree.
And that's why I've always been a po.
I mean,
I,
I think it's incredibly foolish to deny that,
but people find comfort in denying yes.
They find comfort in main tribal.
Yeah.
They find confidence in them.
US versus them.
This is the classic.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
It's,
it's a,
it's a simplified view of the world and it's,
it's foolish and dangerous actually.
Yeah.
Um,
now sometimes you're at war with an enemy,
you know,
it's me or him and uh,
or us or them,
there are circumstances in which it's a different survival.
Yes.
Survival of in that mode.
Yeah.
I get it.
But,
um,
but you know,
but I think the a kind of worldview which says we are good,
they are evil.
Um,
as we've been saying in different kinds of ways,
in different parts of our conversation is I think,
foolish and wrong and ultimately self-injurious.
Actually.
Um,
so.